ལོ་བཞི། འ་་་འཛིན་གྲྭ་
འ་་་སྔོན་འགྲོ་གཉིས་པ།
སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)། ཡོད་(བ་)བ་ཕྱུག་གཅིག་འདུག ཡོད་(བ)།
སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཡོད་(བ)། བྱིའུ་གཅིག་ཕུར་དུས་ཡོད་(བ)།
རེད་བ། བུ་མོ་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་སླེབས་སོང་ད། ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་རྩེད་བ་སོང་ད། ཁོ་ནང་ལ་ཁ་ལག་ཟ་འདུག
དུག་སློག་བཀྲུ། གདོང་པ་བཀྲུ། སོ་བཀྲུ་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཉལ་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད)།
བུ་གཅིག་འང་དགོང་དག་ཞོགས་ཀས་ནང་ལ། དགོང་དག་ཞོགས་ཀས་སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽དགོང་དག་ཞོགས་ཀས་ཡོད་(བ་)མར་ནང་ལ། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽དགོང་དག་ཞོགས་ཀས་གདོང་པ་བཀྲུ། སོ་བཀྲུ།
གཟུགས་པོ་བཀྲུ་།
ཉལ་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽བུ་མོ་གཅིག་མར་འགྲོ་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།
ཁོ་མར་བུ་མོ་གཅིག་མར་བྲོས་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽གདོན་འདྲི་སླེབས་རེད་ད་ནང་ལ། ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་བྲོས་འགྲོ་རེད་བྱིའུ་མཉམ་དུ།
དེ་ནས་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཙི་ཙི་མཉམ་དུ་ཡོད་(བ་)རྩི་རྩི་མཉམ་དུ་༼ཨ་ནས་༽
ཡོད་(བ)། ཁ་ལག་ཟ་དུས་ད་ཁོ་གཉིས་བྱིའུ་ད་བུ་མོ་ད་ཙི་ཙི་མཉམ་དུ་ཁ་ལག་དུས་
༼ཨ་ནས་༽དགོང་དག་ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་འ་་་ཡོད་(བ)།
འ་་་ལབ་དགོས་བས།
སོ་བཀྲུ་གདོང་པ་བཀྲུ་གཟུགས་པོ་བཀྲུ་༼ཨ་ནས་༽སློབ་གྲྭ་འགྲོ ༼ཨ་ནས་༽གཉིད་ཁུག་
ནང་ལ་
དུག་སློག་གོན།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཡོད་(བ་)བྱིའི་མཉམ་དུ་ཡོད་(བ)།
བྱིའུ་མཉམ་དུ་
ཞི་མི་ག་འདྲས་ཡོད་རེད་ལབ་དགོས་བས། ཡོད་(བ)།
མེའུང་། མེའུང་། མེའུང་ལབ་གི་འདུག ཁྱིས་ག་འདྲ་ལབ་གི་འདུག་ལབ་དགོས་བས། ཝའོང་། ཝའོང་ལབ་གི་འདུག
བ་ཕྱུག་གིས་ བའོ་ལབ་གི་རེད།
ཙི་ཙི་གིས་ཙིའུ་་ཙིའུ་ལབ་གི་རེད།
བྱིའུ་གིས་ཡོད་(བ)། ཙེའུ་ཙེའུ་ལབ་གི་རེད།
བུ་མོ་དེ་གིས་
གོས་སློག་གོན་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽བུ་མོ་དེ་གཞས་བཏང་རེད་(ད)།
གཞས་འཁྲབ་གི་ཡོད་རེད།
ང་སྤྲད་ད། ཡོད་(བ་)སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)།
བ་ཕྱུག་ཡོད་(བ་)འགྲོ་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།ཞི་མི་གཅིག་ང་མཐོང་སོང་ད་ང་།
ཞི་མི་ད་ཁྱི་ད་བ་ཕྱུག་ད་ཙི་ཙི་ད་ཡོད་(བ)།
བྱིའུ་ད་བུ་མོ་ད་ང་མཐོང་སོང་ད་ང་།
དེ་ཚོ་
ཤིང་ཏོག་དགོས།
ཁོང་ཚོ་ཐག་རིང་པོ་ལ།
ང་འབྲས་ཐུག
ཆུ།
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ་ཁང་པ།
ཁང་པོ་ཨི་འདྲས་ཡོད་(བ)།
དེ་ལ་ཨི་འདྲས་བཟོ་རེད་བ། ང་རྒན་ལགས་གིས་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེས་ལབ་སོང་།
གྲོགས་མོ་
མཆོག་སྒྲོན།
དེ་ནང་ལ་འ་་་
ངང་ལག་ཟ་ཡག
ངང་ལག་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད།
ཨ་ཅག
བྱེ་མ་ལེབ་མེ་ཏོག་སྒང་ལ་བབས་སོང་ད། འོ་དེའི་འགྲམ་ལ་བུ་གཅིག་འདུག་ར།
བུ་དེ་མཉམ་དུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེས་སོང་ད་བྱེ་མ་ལེབ་དེ།
མེ་ཏོག་སྒང་ལ།
མ་རེད་ད་མེ་ཏོགས་སྒང་ལ།